。
首先说一下。
这个片子啊这个片子嗯是92年的一个电影。
他的名字比他的实际年份要老，就闻香识女人这个翻译方式啊，让人家听的觉得他是个六七十年代的电影。但实际上呢他跟肖申克的旧赎就差两年啊。
这个电影在影史上留下。
留下这个这个比较深刻的印记，有几个原因啊嗯第一个原因就是当然是。
阿尔帕希诺的个人魅力啊，阿尔帕西诺的个人魅力。
这是一个原因。第二个原因呢，这个戏确实给了大段的发挥啊，名场面比较多。这部电影在这影史上流传，或者是说至今在自媒体上活跃，得益于他这个的名场面啊。所以说今天给大家选了这部电影。
当然了，我们不是因为它呃很经典，然后很古典，然后又又又又又有名场面而去选择它的。我们选择它肯定是有我们想要学习的地方，而且是有很实用，学了马上就可以用的一些技巧啊。所以说给大家选的这部片子。
当然了，这部片子毕竟也30年了啊，30年前的片子。所以说这个。
他的税事啊。
偏古典啊偏古典。
但是并不沉闷啊。
首先啊按照惯例，我们看一部电影，先看他的信息节拍。
我曾经强调过。
看一部电影，先不要去管他的一句话，故事，他的主题，他的主角，他的类型，先不要去给我管这些东西，先给我拉信息节拍，否则很多同学判断一个电影就贼片面，比如说闻香识女人，那他就觉得那就是泡妞的呗，对吧？这部电影的主题就是如何善待女人。
如何认识女人是吧？很多人就会硬往这边靠，或者是说啊有些同学就会觉得这个人他呃没有亲爹，是继父，然后这个人呢是个孤寡老人，所以肯定是讲父子情是吧？讲人与人之间的亲情是吧？很多同学就会有这样的判断，好吧。
所以说咱们先不要啊下断言，我们先拉信息节拍好吧，这个片子的第一拍。
也就是一分钟啊，先交代了一下一个名校的环境啊，非常明确的用几个镜头交代这个学校非常的庄严啊，交代这是个名校很牛逼的一个地方，是吧？
为什么要这么交代呢？那必然是与我们的主角有关系。第一拍啊，第一分钟交代名校环境，这样的一个名校环境，而且是个高中。但是呢在这样一个这个名校的这种环境里面。
竟然有一个。
找兼职的查理啊，我们的这个主角查理。
跟我重名啊，正在找兼职。这这个这个一看他不是就不是富家子啊。然后呢同时交代了什么不良的那些少爷们呢，也包括校长呀、校长的豪车呀，对吧？校校长的捷豹啊，90年代捷豹在英国是豪车啊，这个同学们年轻的同学可能不知道，刚进中国的时候也100多万啊。
然后呢，他的同学们呢都在筹划一些奢侈的旅行，虽然是高中生啊，但是呢由于是有钱人家的小孩都在筹筹划一些旅行。
然后呢，和主角形成对比，他们甚至啊会戏弄一下主角对吧？邀请哎跟我们一块玩啊，是吧？
当然了，大家都知道他是拿助学金的，他不可能去履行。
然后呢，这里其实第一场就是交代时空环境以及主角的。
龟壳啊，主角的龟壳它是一个。
在私立高中，在一个奢侈的私立高中求学的穷小子上来交代主角的龟壳好吧，来第二排第6分钟开始。
我们的主角找到了我们的查理，找到了感恩节兼职啊，然后呢去找的时候呢，呃翻译成上校还是翻译成中校，我觉得不重要啊，我们就先叫他上校吧。嗯这个坏脾气的上校先铺垫了一下啊，而且是。
先出的声音，然后再见到本人，为什么这么处理啊？。
down deepthe man is么。
Ca'm sorryn sirutenel.
26 years on the line, nobody ever busted me four grades before.
好，我们说这个处理方式我们稍微暂停看了一下啊，为什么这么处理呢？两个原因吧，一个原因就是压迫感啊，压迫感。因为这个角色呢脾气非常的不好，好吧，先通通过声音展现他的脾气非常不好，就是这个压迫感啊。
我们说这是第一个原因。
第二个原因。
那就是他的人物设定了，眼睛瞎的是吧？然后在这个节拍里面啊，第二节拍里面见到本人之后，发现他是个瞎子，然后他就是在面试的这个这个frank在面试这个茶理。
为什么呃这这场戏有什么作用呢？展现双方的人设啊，以及两个人这个这个巨大的一些区别和矛盾啊，然后嘞。
赶甚至赶走了然后第三节拍16分钟，我们注意啊，第二拍直接10分钟，这场戏两个人的对话，两个人坐在这里对话直接是1分钟，同学们1分钟啊。
非常古典的处理方式，两个角色对话十分钟交代彼此的人设，交代彼此的区别，交代彼此价值观的对抗。
十分钟同学们这在现代电影里面几乎是几乎是不敢想象的啊。但是你如果接到一个case，人家告诉你，唉，这个角色是阿尔帕希诺演。
是吧这就是我说这种片子也有它的学习的价值啊。
来，当然了，你可以学人家台词的写法，而且你要知道人家为什么这么写啊。
第三拍啊第三拍16分钟，本来要留他要离开啊，因为被撵走了嘛，要离开。但是呢对方的那个挽留啊，对方那个挽留，然后他心软。
留了下来，我们说经过这么一次。
这经过一次反复，相当于把期待拉满啊，get an easy feeling。
Bark is worse than his bite.
You know, he was a great soldier.
我们说这场戏这场戏啊他本来要走，但是最后选择留下，通过这样一个以退为进的戏，把观众的期待调得更高啊。我们说这种情况是经常遇到的啊，第四拍第17分钟。
回到学校的图书馆啊回到学校的图书馆，然后嘞这个。
我们的这个主角查理啊嗯。
在图书馆也打工啊，你看他在图书馆也在勤工俭学，然后来心软寄了一本书给一个坏小子，然后跟这个坏小子一块走出图书馆的时候呢，目睹了一场恶作剧啊，筹备吧。
然后第五拍来到第20分钟啊，就是这个这一帮不良少年富家子啊，就恶搞这个校长，然后嘞把我们的主角陷入了危机啊，我们的主角呢。
被这个呃校长逼问啊，甚至告诉他下周一要开听证会，到时候呢有可能要开除他给他下了一个时间锁啊。第20分钟啊，我们的主角就遭遇了自己的一个大危机，下了一个时间锁啊，下了一个时间锁。
然后呢，甚至用哈佛的一个名额去勾引这个主角啊，我们说把这个奖励也拉到最大啊，就告诉你，你如果出卖他们，对吧？我给你哈佛的奖学金，让你保送你上哈佛，你如果不出卖他们就开除啊。
同时呢那帮这个这个这个不良少年啊也来做他的工作，让我们的呃角色陷入了一个。
Dlema啊陷入了两难境界，Dlema还记得吗？同学们。
有多少同学记得我说过困境这个知识点得来吗？
第六拍28分钟啊，正式接受这个工作，也就是踏上了这个征程啊。嗯结果一一接手这个工作就有新的麻烦，发现上校要出远门啊。嗯，在这里呢继续啊继续了强化了一下我们这个呃上校的人设啊，这个注重仪表和尊严啊。
当然了，也非常的爱喝酒。
因为喝酒这件事情也不断的铺垫啊。
在这里呢嗯很明显的查理捂不住这个老头，他要照顾这个老头嘛，但是他捂不住他，因为这个老头主意可正了，是吧？
，然后呢甚至要带着他去纽约，所以说把期待拉满啊，把这个危机的期待拉满，这是就是前六拍啊，前六拍。
色时代的一来到第七拍啊，35分钟。
在飞机上啊嗯我们的主角开始了快乐的时光啊，刚刚踏上征途嘛，踏上征途，要开始见识一些伙伴呀，见识一些美好的东西。他们俩踏上飞机之后呢。
这个上校就是开始展现自己闻香识女人的这个技能啊，而且呢有一个呃他对异性的一个自己的观点啊，又有一个一段大段的台词。嗯，这里其实不是那么的提倡，有大段的台词，因为这里调节奏，但是还是那句话啊，因为这部戏就是这么量身定制的。
所以说呃他在这里说了一段4分钟的台词。
然后第八节班啊倒也不是很长啊，对于这部戏的整个的时长以及他单场的时长来看说，这部戏4分钟吧也不是特别长吧，39分钟正式进入游戏时间。
头等舱呀、顶级酒店呀、礼宾车呀、豪华饭店呀，它里面那个豪华冠豪华饭店，就是纽约那个中央公园里面的那个饭店啊，非常有名。
然后嘞。
为什么去奢侈的？
这个这个如此奢侈的生活，有这么多东西呢？
呃，能够看出来我们的这个上校不断的回忆啊，他要找回从前的一些的荣耀啊，这里就开始很明显了。我们的这个主角一直在回忆什么呢？一直在回忆他没瞎之前啊，他拥有就是他人生风光的时候。
所玩的那些东西，他现在要重新玩一遍，明白这意思吧？基本上展现出来这个上校啊，在想找回他人生的荣光啊。
当然了，除了头等舱鼎级酒店李宾车、豪华饭店这些事情以外啊，为什么说他想找回从前的荣光呢？他不断的到了每个地方都提人，都跟人家说，我以前来过，但是可能都过去20多年了，人家谁还记得你对吧？
然后与此同时呢，他一直展露出来，他想找一个那个有偿陪训啊，嗯我们得注意措辞啊，因为这毕竟是在网络上传播的课程，你们明白就可以了啊。
来第九拍来到第43分钟。
在两个人在李斌车上的时候啊，我们的主角查理的在学校的困境展现一下啊。
嗯，因为查理在学校的困境嗯，那个观众是知道的，在这里呢展现给另外一个主角啊，frank两个人的困境都很重要啊，记得为什么这里单独一拍，虽然只有一分钟，但是单独一拍主角那个那个我们的查理的困境也要展示啊来。
第10个节拍。
第45分钟，两个人在饭店吃饭啊。
然后嘞，frank发现自己被骗了啊，只能留下来。因为他本来告诉他，那你今晚就回去吧，但其实是骗他嗯，骗他呢。
但是上校也告诉你，你你可以知道我的计划，对吧？我就是想要享受生活啊，甚至享受美女。然后呢呃在这之后我要了断我自己。
然后听了这个话之后呢，查理基本上就走不了了啊，这是第十拍。当然了，第十拍这里还有一个细节。
展现我们主角的洞察力啊，展现上校的洞察力，就是进入这种高档饭店啊。
是需要穿西装的，同学们。
进入这种高档饭店啊，是必须要穿西装的。
然后我们的这个。
我们这个茶理作为一个小朋友呢，肯定是是是是没有西装的。所以饭店会提供给这样的客人一件临时的西装啊，穿着，然后不要影响整个饭店的就餐环境啊这个。
呃，这是个小伏笔，因为下面一场戏。
frank就送了查送给查理一套西装，然后来到第十一拍啊，第十一拍第十一拍也就是第50分钟。
我们的导师开始给学生下指令。
开始暗示传承啊，只有一分钟的一场小戏，但是这是一个开端啊，我们的导师开始很凶的给学生下指令，开始暗示传承啊。
这在还拉你。
Many men far better than you have executed that courtesy.
第十 smart。
你败。
Has got sharper radar than the noutilus.
Don't fuck me, Charlie.
十二节拍第51分钟，然后就是早上做西装那场戏了啊，我们的franknk很潇洒的做西装啊，这个因为他是个意大利后裔嘛，所以对西装还是情有独钟的，必须三件套是吧？必须有手绢领带手绢是吧？各种全套，然后嘞嗯很贴心的是给查理也做一套啊。
小菲。
在这里。
又有。
又进一步。
推进了查理的困境，怎么推进的呢？通过查理打电话啊，进一步了解了查理的困境，然后继续强留查理。
甚至给了查理解决这一问题的一些暗示。当然，这里的暗示是反的，这里他怎么他劝查理怎么解决问题啊？
他劝查理妥协是吧？他劝查理出卖自己的朋友。
好吧。
这里是。
说你要实实物是吧，这是第十二节拍的时。
第十三节拍的时候呢。
两个人一块去拜访弗兰克的哥哥。
然后呢，在那儿吃了顿感恩节晚餐啊，感恩节我们说是很重要的。在美国相当于是家人团聚的一个节日。所以说他去见了见他的亲人啊，他在这个世上。
为数不多的血脉之亲啊，他的哥哥，然后他去见了他的哥哥之后，吃了顿饭，但是这顿饭吃的并不愉快啊，自己也不受欢迎，当然自己也很没有礼貌，然后不欢而散，然后对方呢也揭他的伤疤，扒了他过去的遭遇，对吧？
然后吃了顿饭，两个人从哥哥家走了出来。呃，虽然是这个亲情之旅很失败，但是我们的双男主啊感情是得到了发展。从这场戏开始，两个人的感情往正向发展了一下。
甚至有个标志性的动作，就是查理可以去服上校的。因为之前上校是不让别人主动扶自己。
在这里这个小的细节啊在这里这个小的细节展现了两个人的感情进展啊，然后同学说的对，上校去为查理辩护啊，这些都是一些细节。
通过这场戏啊，两个人的感情是有进展的，因为这是一个呃含有浓重的伙伴之情元素的这么一个一个一个一个电影。所以说这个打点很重要啊，来第1四拍。
也就是第六19分钟。在酒店里呢，我们上校又在那练习，安装自己的那个手枪啊，实其实是就是想告诉他回到从前啊，他想回到从前，然后呢，我们的查理想打电话告诉Frank的亲人说这个frank要自杀的这些事情，但是被阻止了，甚至被强留最后一天，说你还你在待最后一天就行了。
然后两个人呢因为这这把枪进行谈判。
我们的查理呢竟然胜利了啊，小小的胜利了一把，把这个枪留住了。
两个人呢也都发现了自己的共同。两个人在这场戏里面啊，在第69分钟这场戏里面，两个人发现了共同点。也就是说两个人在这里啊感情其实达到了一个阶段性的小胜利。
阶段性的小胜利呢。
发现了一些彼此的共同点。
两个人都是坚持原则的人。
Thisose sky has green life, I hope have wonderful.
325原 people do45。
他会虚回。
我谁？
where you go, New Hampshire,You got no money, how you can do that.
Karen's number tastes like Albany.
har来。
开。
All I want from you.
对。
不外的。
One last tour of the battlettlefield.
I can get around a city like New York.
本来。
Sometimes need a point in the right direction.
我得 say这。
What's one day between friends?
谁那 day.
give me weapon份.
这育。
I'm a lieutenant colonel, United States Army, I'm not giving my fucking gun anyone now what are you drinking?
Carold this is unaccept unaccept What you give me that prep school crap for unaccept What have they done the agon out of the boy?
P in Harvard Business School.
能 give me bullet。
You do see the sense it Charlie, don't you。
I can't chew the lead anymore.
So why should来写。
Tbes provision.
I mean, there's no one.
W't a terror herring with me anymore.
抱好歉啊。
没了去干了。
上 like个 guy, lives of a binal lar.
好啊。
这场戏。
两个人呢开始找到了一些理解沟通的一些共同点。因为上一场戏，两个人其实感情是有进展的啊，在这里呢其实是两个人已经开始成为朋友了啊，为什么说他两个人开始成为朋友了呢？
从下面就可以看出来了。第十五拍。
第76分钟，两个人在理发店那个刮胡子啊，然后开始作为朋友交流，语气都变了啊，两个人开始作为朋友交流，他依然在劝查理告密啊，劝查理告密。
然后查理呢透露了这件事情。
透露了这件事情更多的信息，包括修长校长要收买自己。
然后在这里有一台词直接说出了我们课上给大家讲的这种情况，主角需要要有的情况，对吧？
呃，76分钟看看啊。
Ease the blow.
By a drink.
艰难的选择。
为什么要把画面停在这里？就是让大家看看这个单词以后这个单词要会写。
而且同时告诉你们，查理老师对于困境找的这个单词是有多准？
同学们，主角有困境，这种方法论是查烈老师总结了。但是我要给这个困境选一个单词，同学们。
正常来说，学会选一个difficult。
card是吧。
或者是其他什么单词，但是。
得雷嘛。
点来嘛当然了，英英音和美音读法不一样啊。
但是有没。
精准。
主打一个精准ok。
来下一个啊，第16拍，也就是第79分钟啊，两个人开始干什么嘞？两个人开始共谋了是吧？两人关系好了吗？你帮助过我，我也帮助过你了。两个人是不是要开始共谋了？同学们啊。
两个男人共谋，你说能干啥？同学们，你们告诉我，两个男人一老一小，两个人共谋，你说能干啥？
那不就是喝酒泡妞吗？是不是两个人开始喝酒泡妞，对吧？并且啊在这个呃饭店里啊展现了这个呃这个这个跳舞的这个技能啊，传世的名场面呃这我们的我们的这个。
呃，Frank上校啊呃展现了自己的风采，在第十六拍里啊传世名场面。
嗯，第1七拍来到第89分钟。
我们的这个frank啊就是上校这位呃上校去参加这个有偿陪训啊，参加这个付费约会。
然后呢很紧张。
然后我们的这个主角像送孩子一样啊，送他去参加这个像送孩子上学一样，送他去参加这个付费约会。
同时，他在车里等这个franknk回来的时候呢。
又打了一个电话给那帮同学啊，他那帮富家子同学发现对方没有任何原则可言啊，完全不守信，完全不守信用。
第十八拍来到93分钟。
是吧。
嗯，在酒店里。
嗯，上校一很反常的没有起床，然后查理有点担心去看他。
发现上校今天啊完全颓了。
为什么呢？
为什么上校颓啦？
因为上校的医愿清单全部都完成了。同学们，他当时列了一个遗愿清单，最后一个就要泡个妞嘛。
现在已经生无可恋。
然后呢，上校坚持要让查理走，但是查理不肯走。
很着急。
然后这时候呢，他想到了一个办法，就是上校不是说过自己第二喜欢的事情，虽然是说远远比不上第一，但是第二喜欢的事情是法拉利吗？
所以说。
为了鼓舞上下的士气。
我们这个。
查理就勾引他说，咱俩去开法拉利吧。
然后第1九拍来到了第97分钟，两个人去租法拉利。然后这个销售员呢开始不愿意租给他们。但是我们这时候我们的这个。
flan克又展现了自己的口才以及超能力啊，花钱。
搞定了这件事情，两个人。
开路上车，但是上校还是不开心啊，因为他是坐车的嘛，然后查理决定让上校来开啊，查理决定让上校来开车，然后瞎子飙车。
名场面瞎子飙车对吧？两个人玩嗨了啊，两个人玩。
第20拍。
也就是第104分钟，两个人被警察拦停，然后蒙混过关啊，蒙混过关。
然后进入狂欢后的失落，因为最后一个愿望也完成了啊。第21拍来到第107分钟，上校开始寻死，横穿马路啊，横穿马路寻死，然后摔倒在路中央，精神完全崩溃啊，回到景酒店之后呢呃上校的生活已经坍塌了。
同时另外一个主角，我们查理的世界也即将坍塌啊也即将坍塌，他铁定要被开除了。然后第22节拍第112分钟上校呢支开查理，让他去帮自己买药买烟。但是查理感觉到不对劲儿。
没有去买。
呃，及时回来，发现上校已经穿戴整齐，准备赴死。
穿戴穿上它。
有勋章的军服啊，准备体面的离去。
然后两个人争吵起来。
在争吵的过程中，上校甚至吸言，要领养茶理啊，这是个暗示。其实他需要有新的希望啊，他需要传承。
然后查理呢也理解到frank的痛苦啊，夺枪马行的。
第2三拍啊，骂彻底骂醒了之后呢，第2三拍。
第123分钟，两个人开始平静的交流，上校说出了自己的终极梦想。
其实他想要一个能够厮守一生的爱人。
查理哄他把他哄得很开心，但是两个人错过了飞机，两个人错过了飞机。
然后第24拍126分钟。
他们俩呢就坐这个man尼开的这个呃礼宾车。
回。
回去啊，然后。
查理的世界即将要崩塌，因为他面对审判，而且他缺乏家人的支持啊，因为人家都是富家子嘛，富家子都是有家人支持的，他没有。
然后第25拍129分钟，两个人在学校告别啊，这个告别单独一拍，因为这个告别还是蛮重要的。
两个人告别啊。
第26拍131分钟，听证会上听证会上呢查理被审判，然后对方呢当然带了爸爸来啊，然后校长在那演讲。
勾嘎旯的是吧？这时候我们的另外一个男主frank入场。
来支持查理，并且宣称自己是以家长的身份来支持查理，展现他的口才啊，随嘴胡扯胡扯。
然后第二7拍审判开始。
审判开始。
那个对手啊坐在对面的那个有有爸爸保护的那个对手给贡献了。然后呢。
出卖了朋友，然后呢把而且把查理推到了前面，但是查理依然不愿意撒谎，不愿意出卖别人。
然后第2028拍，也就是1441分钟。
最全篇最经典的场面啊，我们的这个阿尔帕希诺的经典演讲替查理出头的这段经典演讲啊，载入萤史的这段经典演讲是第28拍第29拍也就是第147分钟纪律委员会呢判定查理无罪。正义得到了伸张，也就是查理的困境。
率先得到解除啊。
第30part就第149分钟。
我们这个老弗兰克的困境竟然也奇迹的解决啊，政治老师跑过来向上校表达好感。
上校泡妞啊，查理助攻，这场戏有两场作用，一个是。
完整了我们的frank。
对吧第30拍149分钟这场戏啊。
完成了我们的frank。
有时候这好莱坞编剧哈。
也是挺犟气的呢。
这场戏更重要的作用是什么？成为了彼此，互为彼此，查理开始帮他助攻了，甚至帮他吹牛逼。
我们说伙伴之行两个人要成为彼此的呀，交换位置了。然后第31拍也就是来到第151分钟。
我们这个frank回到家啊，两个人非常干脆的告别，没有什么依依不舍。为什么？因为是朋友吧，明天还可以见嘛，那还样。
你看这场戏啊非常明确，他跟那个司机man尼道别的时候呢，反而会多给对方点钱，跟对方客套几句，为什么呢？因为确实未必下次能见到了，但是对方是一个非常棒的人，所以多给对方点钱，说点说点很好的语言，对吧？说点很好的留下美好回忆的话。
但是呢跟这个。
跟我们这个主角呢。
跟我们的这个主角这个呃查理呢。
两个人已经是朋友了，而且住的又这么近，对吧？我住这儿，你在这儿上学，那么明天再见呗，后天再见呗，对吧？或者周末见呗，干嘛这个干嘛要这个这个课堂呢？对不对？而且我们说在这部电影当中啊。
长篇大论实在是太多了。
在这里收一那么一下，反而是挺高级的对吧？在这部电影里面，长篇大段的台词已经说够了，两个人在这里确实也不需要再说了来。
当然了，上校回来之后啊，也开始跟孩子们很友善，呼应了开头啊，呼应了开头。这个呃这个这个这个这个他跟孩子们很冷漠啊，在这里呢其实就是。
他已经开始热爱生活，对吧？发现自己的价值。
同学们。
就是这样一部电影啊呃30多个节拍，这个电影153分钟非常的这个长啊，但是名场面也非常多，这部电影成为传世经典，它的名场面。当然了，这些名场面全都是阿尔帕希诺的啊，全都是阿尔帕西诺的。
与这个也有关系，所以我们挑几个名场面，我们看一下，回顾一下，好吧。
第一个名场面。
飞机上的演讲。
也就是说，两个人在踏上征程，坐上头等舱飞机的时候。
frank向查理展现自己的人生观价值观。这里这一场堪比。
堪比华尔街之郎里。
那场人生观演讲啊，这场戏堪比华尔街之郎里面那一场。
好吧，一场人生观大戏啊。
一场人生观的演讲看一下吧啊。
对有。
哦，本来这100万。
我认为呢。
你谁？
不北的。
这也是。
谢得有谁别谁。
They ever buried in news.
In a mountain of curls just.
Go to sleep forever.
Or lips.
And when they touched yours were like, at first.
Swa of wine after he had just crossed the desert.
开气。
不啊。
Big one, little one。
Niples staring right out at you like secret search lights.
Ls.
I don't care if they're Greek columns.
我 sick handsstein with.
What's between him?
Passport Devon.
I need a drink.
Yes, Miss Sim.
There's only two syllables in this whole wide war.
Here.
我谁。
Are you listening to me son, I'm giving you pearls here.
I guess you really like women.
Above all thing.
A very, very distant second.
Charlie.
前面。
This is just the story of your education son.
这场戏啊。
这场戏。
嗯，当年在。
这场戏当年在这个在荧幕上的地位真的堪比。
华尔街之狼里面的场戏华尔街之狼大家记得吧？唉，其实改天可以给大家拉一下华尔街之狼啊，华尔街之狼还是不错的。
也有名场面啊，来，我们再看下一个名场面。
也就是最著名的那场。
啊，不是最著名的第二著名的那场。
泡妞戏啊。
Mistakes in the tango.
Not like life.
That's what makes tangles so great. If you make a mistake, get all tangled up.
那就 try。
All right, I'll give it a try.
O down son.
s the floor is about 20 by 30 and you're at the long end.
这 was样扎，有 didn't大 the变 on right。
。
A one incredible dance set.
好。
看来这场戏争议很大啊，因为一旦涉及到男女啊、男女朋友啊，我们同学都很喜欢讨论啊。
行。
我来说一下我的观点好吗？同学们，希望能够帮助到大家去理解这种戏。为什么很多人是喜欢的，或者是说在很多人眼里会觉得这场戏很美，很优雅啊，并没有什么不适。是这样的，我来说一下我的观点。同学们。
如果啊。
如果你心里想这样的问题，比如说这个女的又不想跟她的男朋友分手，她为什么要接受别人的搭讪？
对吧那他是不是不要脸了？
或者是说这几个人，这两个人明明知道人家有男朋友，还要去跟人家搭讪，跟人家跳舞。他们是不是坏人呢？是不是图谋不轨呢？
呃，你如果有这样的想法。
其实就是略微有点直男癌了，实际上是这样。
你面对一个有魅力的人。
不管他是长相有魅力。
还是说他的谈吐有魅力，还是说他的学问有魅力。
你去想跟他结识，想跟他聊天，我觉得都是可以的。
你如果想，那如果聊天就是想跟他睡觉，不想睡觉，为什么要跟他聊天？你如果有这样的逻辑，那其实啊是你自己的想法呢会过于的。
其实有点对两性之间的这个理解啊。
有点有点有点窄了啊，有点窄。
对吧这么去想就。
就非常的传统。
实际在现代社会里啊。
我觉得。
人与人之间还是应该多多关注共同点。所所以从这个角度来讲啊，实际上目前来说呃，大部分观众啊大部分年轻观众是能够接受。
这种戏的啊，所以你不用去担心啊，你不用去担心。
对，不要去总是从一个睡觉的逻辑去理解问题啊。总来看下一个名场面啊，下一个名场面141分钟。
全剧最名场面的名场面来了啊，save your hide anythingth short of that。
stay。
喂。
见了们。
When a shit hits the fan, some guys run and some guys stay, here's Charlie facing the fire and as George hiding in big Daddy's pocket.
And what are you doing?
Youre gonna to reward George.
Destroy charm.
Are you finished, Mr. Slaade, No, I'm just getting warmed up.
I don't know who went to this place, William Howard Taft, William Jennings bride, William Ta, whoever, their spirit is dead, if they ever had one, it's gone, you're building a rat ship here.
A vessel for seago and snitchches, and if you think you're preparing these minnows for manhood, you better think again because I say you are killing the very spirit, this institution proclaims it instills.
What I sham what kind of a show are you guys putting on here today I mean the only class in this act is sitting next to me and I'm here to tell you this boy's soul is intact, it's nonnegotiable, you know how I know someone here and I'm not going to say who offered to buy it.
Only Charlie here wasn't selling sir youre out of order I don, I show you I order you don't know what that is Mr. Tras, I'd show you but I'm too old, I'm too tired, I'm too fucking blind if I were a man I was five years ago, I'd take a flame throw at this place.
I don't on, who the hell do you think you're talking to?
I've been around, you know.
There was a time I could see, and I have seen boys like these younger than these, their arms torn out, their legs ripped off, but there is nothing like a sight of an amputated spirit, there is no prosthetic for that.
You think you're merely sending this splendid foot soldier back home the argon with his tail between his legs, but I say you are executing his soul."
哎，外。
Because he's not a bad man.
Bd men, you hurt this boy, you're going to be bad bums, the Lodia and Harry, Jimmy, Trent, wherever you are out there, fuck you to.
Stand down, Mr. Sla, I'm not finished.
As I came in here.
I heard those words, cradle of leadership.
Well when the bow breaks, the cradle will fall and it has fallen here, it has fallen, make us a men creators of leaders be careful what kind of leaders you're producing here I don't know if Charlie's silence here today is right or wrong, I'm not a judge or jury, but I can tell you this.
He won't sell anybody out to buy his future.
And that my friends is called integrity.
That's called courage now that's the stuff leaders should be made of.
I have come to the crossroads in my life.
I always knew.
What the right path was.
Without exception, I knew, but I never took it, you know why?
It was too damn hard.
Now here's Charlie, he's come to the crossroads, he has chosen a path, it's the right path, it's a path made a principle that leads to character.
Let him continue on his journey.
You hold this boy's future in your hands committee.
It's a valuable future.
不ieve me。
Don't destroy it, protect it.
Embrace it.
It's going to make you proud one day, I promise you.
放多我。
兄弟们，请来。
disciplinaryary committee will take this matter under advisement in closed session.
好，最大的名场面呃，回答一下同学们的问题啊，有人觉得查理告密这件事情吧呃设计的不好，觉得觉得查理其实可以告密，告密也没什么，对吧？有些同学会觉得查查理告密这件事情吧，查理有点过于坚持了，其实可以。
告发那三个小子，那三个小子又不是好东西，对吧？我们会有同学有这样的担心，会有这样的想法啊。呃，这个我来给大家解释一下啊，我来给大家解释一下。
这个问题为什么会是这样？
我来给大家解释一下这个问题，为什么是这样。
这是文化决定的。
你们做事这个在理解一个东西的时候啊，一定要有。
这个了解从宏观上了解啊，因为西方国家它的组织结构是从下而上。
也就是说，我们这一群人先组成一个团体。
然后我们再推选一个人组成上面一个团体。
然后上面这一群人再推选一个团体，推选一个人组成在上面一个团体，它是这样一个结构。所以说你的你要对你团体的人负责任。
你不可能向上面那个管理你们这个团体的人告密，因为他不是你的人，他不是你们的人。
这就是。
自下而上的一个。
一个一个。
自下而上的一个组织结构。
而咱们呢是自上而下的组织结构，先有这个人，然后他在安排下面的事情。
安排下面的人，然后他呢在安排下一层面的人，所以我们需要向上负责。
明白吗？咱们的文化里，咱们是需要向上负责。咱们在一个班级里，我们需要对老师负责，对班干部负责，而不是对同僚负责。
这个问题就是他的文化不太一样。
明白这个意思吧？没有对错啊，文化不一样。
同学们。
没有对错，文化不一样。所以在西方这种。
组织结构里面告密是一个非常非常大的事儿。
在告密在西方这个文化里面，告密是个非常非常大的事儿。因为你出卖的是你的同僚。
上面那个人是另外一拨人，他不是我们的管理者。
你能理解这个意思吗？
同学们，你能理解这个意思吗？
这是组织结构造成的啊。
咱们是另外一种结构。
咱们是另外一种结构，咱们需要对上负责，对吧？我们我们的文化里面，我们对上面那个人负责。所以我们听上面那个人呢，他问我们什么，我们必须告诉他。
好吧，所以说这个没有什么好争论的啊，你要理解它是文化不同，没有什么好争论的。
来，我们就着这段演讲。由于这段演讲是全篇的高潮啊，最最著名的名场面。就着这段演讲，他已经几乎把这个片子的主题喷到我们脸上了。
说了两遍。
同学们。
来理解一下这个电影的主题。
有同学是忠诚，怎么可能是忠诚呢？
我们双男主上校那边有忠诚可言吗？
什么忠诚啊，怎么能是忠诚呢？上校那边有忠诚可言吗？我再跟你们说一下什么正直原则，我跟你们说一下来喂。
学了。
When the shit hits the fan, some guys run and some guys stay.
这是一句。
出事情的时候。
有的人会面对，有的人会逃跑。
这句话在前面也说过。
出事情的时候，有的人会面对，有的人会逃跑。再看一下，后面又说了一遍，之前也说过这句话。
Thats好 courage。
Now that's the stuff leaders should be made of.
Now I have come to the crossroads in my life.
I always knew.
What the right path was.
Without exception, I knew.
But I never took it.
You know why.
It was too damn hard.
Now here's Charlie, he's come to the crossroad.
He has chosen a path. It's the right path.
It's a path made a principle.
That leads to character.
在这里又说了一遍。
面对问题的时候，或者遇到人生。
十字路口的时候。
其实我们每个人内心都知道应该走哪条路。
但是我们往往没有选择去走正确的路。
因为正确的路太难了。
太苦了。
因为正确的路要负重前行。
所以这部电影。
就是在讲。
抉择。
两个人都有dle马。
都在抉择。
上校眼睛瞎了。
没有家庭的爱，没有事业，没有人生的希望，没有爱情。
他想死。
死是正确的路吗？
死是简单的路。
他想选那条。
简单的路。
我们的查理也是。
他遇到了一个dle。
出卖同学还是不出卖同学？这帮同学不是个东西，对他也不好。
然后呢，出卖他们之后可以上哈佛。
所以说出卖他们是什么？是简单的路，出卖他们是简单的路。
但是保持良知，坚持自己是困难的路。
抉择。
又是抉择。
所以这个电影的主题。
是抉择。
当然了，有些同学说是直面人生，勇敢面对也对啊也对，最后的选择肯定鼓励我们勇敢面对嘛，走那条正确而艰难的路，对吧？最精准的表述方式，这个电影的主题是抉择，或者是说面对抉择的时候，我们要去走那条。
正确而艰难的道路。
最后两个人都走了正确而艰难的道路。
所以这个电影讲的是。
双男主。
对吧双男主一个是。
想要主动放弃生命的瞎子。
是吧瞎子上校老年人。
另外一个呢是遭受了一个不公平待遇，前途即将被毁掉的名校贫困生。
这样一对人物组合。
面对各自人生选择的时候，面对各自人生艰难选择的时候。
互相帮助。
选择都选择了正确的道路。
什么人什么情况，什么事儿，什么人呢？
一对主角什么情况呢？面对各自人生的艰难选择。
做了一件什么事呢？
互相帮助着。
选择了正确的道路。
选择了艰难而正确的道理。
来这部电影我们来看一下啊，选择属于什么？
同学们。
我们说面对一个。
底雷玛我们说有错误的选。
有简单的选择。
最后去做出正确的选择，这是用斯耐德的体系的话，这是哪一种啊？
用斯奈德的体系，我们说这是哪种？
签字的特点。
变迁仪式对吧？变迁仪式非常典型的变迁仪式。面对一个人生选择，面对一个人生变故，对吧？我说的是用斯奈德的体系来看啊。
所以这个电影里面有哪三种大的元素，我们来看。
这个电影里面有哪？这个电影如此之长，有哪三三种元素，我们先来捋一下。
伙伴之情是不是挺明显？同学们。
伙伴之情是不是挺明显啊？
伙伴之间挺明显是吧？
变签仪式也挺明显，两个人有各自的变签仪式，遇到的都是生活中会遇到的问题。
第三个元素呢。
两个人还上路了。
两个人上路了。
我们说公路片。
对吧踏上了一条寻死之路。
我们说踏上寻死之路，公路篇。
挺常见的，想要去寻死，完成自己遗愿之后寻死。我们说这种类型片也挺多的。
你看啊。
这个片子。
他这个三个商业元素。
啊，都用了。
伙伴之情。
辩见仪式。
然后还上路。
同学我们来回忆一下为什么。
我为什么大家拉这部片子？
同学们，你们回忆一下。
为什么触不可及那么好看？当时。
触不可及，比起这部片子用的是哪两个？
我们说这部片子用了三个商业元素。
触不可及用的是哪两个？触不可及，用的是伙伴之情。
和。
变签仪式。
一是也是要死，要自杀。
这部片子用的是伙伴仪式、变签仪式以及公路。
触不可及用的是。
前两个。
我们再来想一下。
绿皮书用的是哪两个？
金羊毛和伙伴之起。
对吧伙伴和公路。
那我就知道了。
闻香识女人，他不就是触不可及加绿皮书吗？
你再看看。
闻香识女人是不是就是触不可及加绿皮书啊？
那我们回到我们要学的东西，同学们。
学习的要点来了。
这种片子为什么看起来都挺有逼格的呢？
到底是怎么做到的呢？
你看这三个片子都是得大奖的片子啊，同学们这三个电影都是得大奖的传世制作。为什么这类片子这么占便宜呢？
我们来看一下，像这样这种片子。
怎么去？
怎么去设定？
首先。
我们说人设。
记一下人设，记一下这节课的知识点，我们要学东西啊。
人设。
肯定是要。
相反。
或者是说互补。
但是最近啊我发现有很多同学对于人设相反啊理解的极其刻板。
只要这个是好人，那个就十恶不赦。
只要这个善良，那个恨不得吃人。在这里我们强调一下啊。
人社互补。
并不是指这两个人。
真的就所有的事情都相反。
明白吗？一个头大，一个就得头小。
一个单眼皮，一个就得双眼皮，不是这样的。
明白吗？
所以说互补的人设啊注意第一点。
不要什么事情都给我搞得相反，要留一个共通之处。
这个共通之处呢是两个人的原则，两个人的善良或者是两个人的坚强。
要留把闪光点做成共通的。
否则他妈谁还爱看喜欢你这俩人。
明白吗？这是我们从这类片子。
高分片里面学的第一点。
不要给我刻板的理解互补。
能明白我在说什么吗？
这是第一个。
共通的要用他们人性光辉的那一面，对吧？讨人喜欢的那一面。
然后呢，相反的互补的呢。
第二个要点啊，做互补做相反的时候啊。
可以多做一些两个人处境上的相反。
明白吗？为什么说你看一个人有家庭，一个人没家庭，这种比较好用呢？因为它是处境相反，不影响两个人的人性。
一个人有钱，一个人没钱，处境相反，不影响两个人的人性，懂吗？
多做处境环境上的相反。
好不好？
只是从这个片子当中，我们先知道人家逼哥高是首先这件事情做对了。
这类片子的逼格高的做对的第二件事情就是善用人生变迁的难题。
我曾经说过，我在课上讲过，我是变签仪式是很容易拿奖。
为什么呢？因为他揭露的是生活当中真实的伤痛。
比如说想自杀，比如说被人冤枉了，对吧？比如说我身体残疾了，比如说我得绝症了。
比如说。
海边的曼彻斯特，我失去孩子了。
这近伤痛很真实。
所以说要善用人生变迁。
比如说。
你现在要写一个伙伴之情，这两个人的互补，你想写这两个人共同成长，那他俩总要遇到问题吧，才能共同成长吧。
遇到的问题。
考虑一下咱们。
变迁意识问题，也就是人生。
大部分人能够共情的那种生活当中的问题。
这一点能学会吗？
给两个人找事儿的时候啊。
考虑一下变签仪式类型的事情。
因为这种事情啊。
逼哥高啊。
然后。
有些同学说了，老师如果都写这种事情，这个片子很沉重啊。
有一种取巧的办法。
就是一个人遇到的是人变迁仪式的事情。另外一个人遇到的是一个。
比较戏剧化的事情。
举个例子。
也带家也带大家看过的一个公路片叫花生酱猎鹰。
故事结构也很像绿皮书，我再说一遍叫花生酱猎鹰。
一个正常人，一个糖宝宝，两个人。
互补上路。
一个人遇到的就是变签仪式的问题。
他哥哥死了，他唯一人唯一的亲人，他哥哥死了，他现在在世界上没有亲人了。
变迁意识。另外一个人呢是梦幻型的一个目标，他要去找他的偶像，要追星。
你看一下这两个目标，一个人哥哥死了。
在这个世界上，他不再有亲人了，这个主角这这显然是仪式变迁呀，我们都能共情，因为我们都会失去亲人，我们也都失去过亲人，是吧？
户口本上就剩自己了。
一个人。
这是一个角色。另外一个角色呢出去追星，我要追星，理解这种处理方式吧。
那么一个人就会负责沉重，一个人就会负责搞笑，然后两个人就可以互相治愈。
两个人就可以互相去愈，所以同学们也可以考虑这种方法。
我再强调一遍啊。
给。
伙伴之情的角色。
制造困境的时候。
考虑一下变迁意识。
因为逼格高。
好懵。
容易感人。
也好卖。
但是。
如果。
你觉得？
这样太沉重，不利于发挥你的商业感觉，或者你的天马行空，或者你的幽默细胞。
可以考虑一半一半。
而且一半一半之后，你会发现很好写，一个人负责治愈，一个人负责是吧？沉重，一个人负责分批，一个人负责叫停。
踩刹车一个踩油门，一个踩刹车。
会非常好用。当然了。
结合这个片子啊。
结合今天这个片子，我们也要强调一下。
在设计变迁仪式的时候，要符合我们的文化和国情。
对吧就好比他这个告密这件事情啊，实际在我们东方文化里面，我们是不太容易。
这个这个。
接受了。
你看他上面他上来就有个约定，就是谁也不许告诉父母。
同学们，这帮小子上来就有个约定，谁也不许告诉父母。你看这个在我们东方文化里面就不太容易接受呀。我们告诉自己的父亲是很正确的。
很正常的是吧？我们一个男孩子遇到问题，跟自己的父亲沟通一下，在我们的文化里面是是是对的。
但是在他们的文化里面是不对的。
所以。
在设计变签仪式的时候，同学们一定要考虑国情。
那我们要求再严格一点。
考虑。
有痛点的过去。
比如我给大家讲过。
漫长的几节。
考工。
是不是？
然后这个这个这个内卷我。
然后生三胎国情，养老国情要考虑咱们的国情，要考虑大部分人的痛点。这节这节课啊这些东西都给我学到。
当然了，还是推荐拓展阅读触不可及。绿皮书、华生酱猎鹰啊，这个同学房贷谈起这个你们都来劲了是吧？
嗯哼。
单身不算是痛点吗？单身很痛吗？
太痛了啊。
典型啊。
好吧。
同学们自己去想一想，好不好？
自己去想一想。
你看。
再回回顾一下啊，同学们。
通过这节课。
我们。
双男主的片子，我们之前应该是拉过片吧。
双男主的片子我们见的多了是吧？双男主都会有伙伴之情，都会他妈先互助再共谋这那。
但是。
叠加变签仪式。
是不是就是有奇效呢？
我们说叠加一个仪式变迁。
是不是就有奇效呢？
因为。
变签仪式里面的主题都是抉择。
都是人生选择，到底勇敢面对还是逃避，就是到底是面对还是逃跑，是所有变迁仪式片子的主题呀，同学们。
我在讲变迁仪式的时候，我都告诉过你们，变迁仪式就是上来先逃避，消极面对，后面再面再积极面对一个错误的方法，一个正确的方法，两个方法角励。
都是这样。
对吧？
有的时候吧。
很多故事他就是有套路。
我们必须得学会它啊运用它。
好吧。
但是还是那句话啊，这些都是咱们内部才能说的。
在外面就不要说这是我说的。
这些走捷径的小招啊，也就是内部说一说啊，外部不要说不要说的这么绝对，不要说哎，我们老师说了都是抉择。
我们老师说了，套一个人。
出去就不要这么说啊，这就是内部课，我们内部理解，内部消化。好吧，我们自己这么想就可以了，不需要让别人也这么想，我们也不去跟别人辩论，我们也不去跟别人讨论，好吧，甚至可以不用跟别人分享。
明白了吗？
那这节课。
就。
差不多就到这儿了吧，好吧。